I think I still need to do my Texas the
April 15th it uses April 15 but if you
mail them then eight it's gonna take a
while I'm I love that SMO and this is
pop our fun-loving and that is
responsible best friend and roommate
he's also two years younger than both of
us and it shows
he knows about new stuff on the internet
way before we do what is damned annual
it's a meme but how does it mean can't
explain a mean what's and knows nothing
about real-world stuff that matters you
file your taxes man no are you going to
do I need to short answer yes
long answer yes Paul five your taxes God
love him I mean he really just doesn't
know what even is a 401 K sometimes he
does stuff that I find immature come on
guys what floor are we going to oh boy
Oh fun
Andy has way more energy than me and Moe
combined I mean the boy can skate all
day all day Moe tends to treat him like
a little brother all I'm saying is at
some point you're gonna like a girl she
might like you back I like playin girls
but it's because he's still so youthful
can I get a coffee yeah you get a
cappuccino
orange soda for me please speaking of he
hates being treated like a baby
I've got our jumbo little man with the
plan
ha ha ha Peter Pan ok he's had I'll just
say but we are the only ones allowed to
baby in well thanks a little guy hey
Mary
well talking like that yeah don't do
this I'm so sorry ok
look sometimes my girlfriends are into
him and that is weird
so tell me about Paul is he single oh
girl he is a baby but it's not bad being
the youngest you've got your whole life
ahead of you and people are gonna look
out for you well at least your friends
will